[Música]
bienvenidos a en 5 minutos con hoy nos
acompaña a carlos eduardo pérez médico
infectólogo de la universidad nacional
de colombia doctor gracias por estar con
nosotros hablemos de las vacunas y es
que más de 48 experimentales contra el
cob y 19 se encuentran en ensayos
clínicos en humanos y de estas 11 están
en fase 3 la última antes de ser
aprobadas hemos visto también en los
últimos días el anuncio de varias
farmacéuticas sobre la efectividad de
sus vacunas qué significan estos
anuncios doctor
realmente es una muy buena noticia
porque no es sorprendente el nivel de
productividad es decir que sea del 95%
que realmente es una buena noticia
porque habla que es una vacuna efectiva
y lo que conocemos preliminarmente es
que sonar un asegura los efectos
adversos no son muy importantes también
que es importante que los estudios han
contemplado minorías étnicas y mayores
de 65 años es una buena perspectiva hay
que tomarla con prudencia pero es una
luz para solucionar este problema
definitivamente quienes deberán son los
encargados de avalar la efectividad de
estas vacunas doctor para su
distribución ahora viene un proceso que
este registro en donde las entidades
gubernamentales con un grupo de expertos
independientes de las casas
farmacéuticas y de los grupos de
investigación evalúan los resultados
verifican que sea cierto
y les dan un ok para que se registre y
así se puede utilizar en cada uno de los
países estas entidades regulatorias
están haciendo un proceso fase algo muy
rápido para que se pueda establecer pero
son grupos totalmente independientes a
los que desarrollaron el ábaco la
revista médica the lancet ha dicho que
la vacuna de oxford es segura en adultos
mayores o una población clave porque son
los que más generan una enfermedad grave
y que también genera una respuesta
inmune y ya va en la segunda fase de
pruebas doctor va también por buen
camino son prometedores estos resultados
son bastante prometedores esta y como
decíamos al principio la nota las más de
100 kva unas que se están desarrollando
esta vacuna tiene la particularidad es
que una sola dosis las otras son dos
dosis y también es segura en la
población mayor sin embargo tenemos que
esperar los resultados evaluarlos para
poder decir que el grupo de población
resumen que vacunas y en qué momento son
buenas noticias es una buena perspectiva
pero tenemos la prudencia necesaria para
estar los resultados definitivos de cada
uno de los estudios y de cada una del
alba con y de que debemos preocuparnos
doctor habrá efectos secundarios serios
al recibir estas vacunas o lo sabremos
cuando se empiecen a masificar a que
sean masivo la vacunación
ya se está haciendo masivamente la
vacuna de estas farmacéuticas tienen en
un brazo 40 mil personas se nota 30 mil
una doctor también otros miles de
personas realmente ya se está haciendo y
las pruebas de seguridad pues son
pruebas bastante satisfactorias y lo que
me preocupa actualmente son los grupos
antivacunas la tergiversación la info
demia en donde se va a tergiversar el
uso de las vacunas y se puede manipular
la información es necesario que todos
hagamos una pedagogía que la vacuna la
solución pero tenemos que vacunarnos
todos para que sea efectiva para todo el
mundo y como no bajar la guardia doctor
por ejemplo en américa latina en la
región la llegada de estas vacunas puede
no ser inmediata
si lo que se calcula es que estas
vacunas podrían llegar en el segundo
semestre el 2021 por eso la mejor vacuna
es que no nos dé ccoo hoy no sabemos en
qué personas le saldrá un código
complejo o un código prolongado o un
código que tenga alguna secuela por eso
hay que seguirse cuidando esperamos que
sean ya pocos meses para que tengamos la
vacuna y está en nosotros en nuestro
comportamiento de que no nos enfermemos
lleguemos en el mejor estado de salud
para que la vacuna sea efectiva
y nos pueda proteger a nosotros a
nuestras familias ya la comunidad nos
quedan 40 segunditos doctor una vez que
lleguen esas vacunas que grupos se deben
de priorizar los médicos que están
combatiendo la enfermedad o algunas
otras grupos de población vulnerables
sin duda el personal de salud que está
en primera línea de ser prioridad lo
mismo las personas con comorbilidades
mayores de 65 años diabéticos e
hipertensos y después de asociados a
seguir vacunando el gobierno de planear
una estrategia autorización de
accesibilidad y de implementación en
todos los lugares para que todos nos
podamos vacunar pero va a ser una
solución al problema y soy muy optimista
al respecto muy bien pues muchas gracias
doctor carlos eduardo pérez por sus
respuestas y recomendaciones
profesionales él es médico infectólogo
de la universidad nacional de colombia
gracias a ustedes por su compañía ya lo
sabes siguen france24
[Música]